stop the show Gang let's talk about that
middle class famous store baby oh baby
coming up to the fourth quarter on that
down to the Finish Line only a few times
to see us gang It's a Good Time come on
out and see the live show to mix a
stand-up comedy plus we played a little
late YG with the crowd it's a great way
to introduce new people to the show so
bring the squad with ya yeah gang this
week we're going to be we have one show
left on sale in Atlanta on uh November
12th and we're going over there to
Charlotte North Carolina uh Philadelphia
sold out you snooze you lose we got some
tickets left for the second show in
Providence Rhode Island in December and
we got some a few tickies left for our
second show in Boston in December get
those hickies let's party gang this
episode is brought to you by our good
friends and established titles with
established titles you can buy as little
as one square foot of dedicated land and
you could start calling yourself or Lord
or a lady I'm a lady kind of guy
nothing wrong with it get me with every
order established titles plants a tree
and works with Global Charities is more
Global reforestation efforts look at
that huh let's go why not title packs
give you at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland good Lord and you get
a certificate with the crest on it boom
right there hit it uh it's an amazing
last minute gift uh it's not a gag gift
it's cool it's fun don't be giving
people Stars give them this this is make
somebody a landowner baby established
titles is running a Black Friday sale
right now plus if you use the code
garbage you'll get an additional 10 off
that off the top go to establish
titles.com garbage to get your gifts now
and help support the show baby
establishtrails.com garbage do it right
mate welcome to another exciting edition
of are you garbage the show where you
find out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and Dave
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out the girl to be classy or
if they're just a big old piece of trash
I almost got me I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antuti's basement she is
around here somewhere okay
my co-host is coming at you man what is
there a writer strike or something
listen I go for a laugh it doesn't
matter yeah I get on base my co is
coming at you from across the table he
is the CEO of Ru garbage forget about
all that though he's my best pal in the
whole wide world and I love them give it
up for KJ Kevin James all right hey I
got a goofy one off out the gates today
daddio thanks for tuning in as always
you gotta give it a Spiel make sure you
rate review subscribe over there on
iTunes do that for us uh full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are Shredder out check that [ __ ]
out subscribe over there do us a solid
uh and then obviously uh patreon.com the
greatest goddamn website of all mother
mother effing time you sign up you get
bonus episodes
ayg every week if you're on a 10 level
get the hard feelings you get the hard
feelings which I gotta be honest with it
is the money maker to run away hit
that's what the people want that's what
the people love it's a gun it's a good
show it's a behind the scenes it's the
HR us screaming at each other people
like it we're having like listen we're
not selling it
we're having a good time over there do
yourself no we're selling it that's
don't listen to the fatty we're selling
this thing all right we're having a good
time over there is the point get over
there and check it out it's a good time
on that beach check it the [ __ ] out we
got a whole [ __ ] ton of content we got
uh for the 20 Level we're doing a bunch
of Vlog stuff uh we're on the road with
Bert Kreischer that one's dropping soon
us on the road me and you and the gym
they got a whole lot of stuff we got
we got the [ __ ] out gang and how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer ex
short and air the magic man makes us all
look good he works the ones and twos and
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
no one's gotta reboot you he might be
doing some defibrillating in a couple of
seconds here because I think I'm having
uh amalgamations give it up for Tebow
McMuffin Toby McMullen what's up dudes
what's up oh man this is gonna ruin the
episode because Foley's gonna spiral but
last night at dinner my mom goes he's
out of antuti jokes huh
[Laughter]
Cindy you ain't lying
if you got it he hit me up
my DMs are open
for professional purposes and wieners
I'll take a wiener
I don't think amalgamation was the word
right for sure wasn't competition is
what I wanted to say okay Dalmatian was
what I wanted to say I don't like
Dalmatians uh uh yeah not that I don't
like them they stared a little snippy
they look like they are inherently
nasty yeah nasty is the word yeah real
yeah they're Snappy don't listen to that
that dog on PAW Patrol they ain't all
sweet like PAW Patrol PAW Patrol not a
bad show listen I was just singing the
theme song probably was rudely
interrupted
Toby Hit the Lights we put it on for the
cat when we leave we put on like a kid's
Network that's what he wants to scare
the [ __ ] out of it dogs hate catchy
hawks eat squirrels
um I got one for you because I know
um
what do you got Kip uh the other day
went out to a nice little town uh
outside of New York City uh Rye New York
ah no well a couple of bucks up there a
couple of dollars couple of doll hairs I
know the guy that used to own the whole
thing rye bread I mean
I made a shitloading pumpernickel
laughs
now we toured um
a farmer nah not really a plantation but
okay they weren't paying minimum wage
they put it to you that way they were in
Union yeah I don't know what you would
call it but he the guy that owned that
owned all of that almost all all of
Westchester at some point wow Johnny
Westchester and he was still working
yeah was it all Moonlight and canoes
back then what are you talking about I
don't know Pete how you met him I didn't
meet him we went and toured the the
facility his house sounds like you were
casing The Joint to be honest
where were you that night October 12th
is what I wanted now I was a Sleepy
Hollow dinner with my kid at the
Headless Horseman ask him he'll back me
up if you can find them
shout out to icky sticky
that kid knew when to get out of town
foreign
Goofy Mickey I don't care we did uh we
did uh he was the Headless Horseman
right
icky no goodbye crane was the Headless
Ichabod Crane was the school teacher
Ichabod Crane was like the guy that was
scared the guy that that the Headless
Horseman oh tormented it was his story
gotcha he worked in the city and got
sent up to Sleepy Hollow to work up
there gotcha well but I think in the Tim
Burton movie he's a detective Johnny
Depp dude the detector The Headless
Horseman's name is Abraham Van Brunt
yeah he was a Hessian Soldier
he was a Hessian Soldier
um I I we we did it uh uh [ __ ] uh
haunted hayride as a kid and I don't
know how they did it or who it was
the neighborhood organized it like my
neighbor did he got like he had like a
big [ __ ] not like a tow truck like a
big uh construction like uh
truck and we all got in the back of it
and he drove a sort of scary [ __ ] the
Headless Horseman drove a bobcat dude
got the big rat out front
now I use canned leaf laughs
so they had I don't know I still can't
do the math of where the [ __ ] he took us
because it was like in the neighborhood
I don't know how they did it but you
looked up on a hill and a guy ran up on
a horse with no like he I guess he had
his shirt
like over his head you know he had like
a big shirt over his head and he was
like looking but you and he dude as like
a six-year-old there was a for sure dude
I remember looking at my mom like let's
call an Uber let's get me the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] he's a daisy nah I don't like
that she's a mechanic in football pads
yeah well you can kind of he had like
you can always as a kid I would always
go like oh I can see the smell the
Miller Light coming down the hill
anybody got a light Jesus Christ say
goodbye if you smell Coors Light and
breath mints and cigarettes run
he's jammed up at a checkpoint somewhere
your license registration in Ed please
when I was
[Laughter]
shout out we haven't seen each other in
a couple of days shout out to Boston
they used to put on a show they would
bring it down there at Halloween after
you did all your candy and all that
stuff and you go down there and uh just
right in the middle of the street from
one building to another they would do
like this little little shitty
production
but they would have some broad up on the
roof with uh wearing a witch's costume
and then they would send a dummy across
a wire yeah you didn't know that when
you were a kid that was big and they a
dummy a scarecrow on a zip line will
[ __ ] you up and then they'd have another
broad on the other side oh dude nope
uh-huh well I don't care how many Kit
Kats you got um adding I didn't like
that show wing and Cadbury Eggs I used
to wait in the car with it running I
didn't like that [ __ ] at all ah dude so
we're up there I don't like witches
now because they're I'll fight a ghost I
don't like witches no you can't punch a
ghost
um witches are scary though
so we're we go to this thing and they
have like uh we just go uh we're like
walking to go to stroll through town and
it happens right up and right we're back
to present Day present day everybody's
got their head on them so we get up
there nice up there took the dog there's
a beach you can take the dogs on turns
into a dog park in the winter time runs
around a little honzi Ponzi in the water
it's a scene you know send your pics
um
so we're like oh let's go get lunch or
whatever so we get over there and like
the main you know how all those towns
have main streets yeah you know what I
mean so we get to over there to the main
street and uh it's blocked off they're
doing their like uh holiday you know uh
Halloween thing for the kids or whatever
they paint there's like you know a
little bake sale like I'll I'll just you
know nice little Street blocked off and
there's bake sales are all right they
have uh lemon square they have a they
have a band there you know it's
entertainment and it's a cut they have a
cover band of like local dads not like
cool spooky songs you would think they
were they were really reliving The Glory
Days dude they were playing like Smoke
on the Water and [ __ ]
dude they I mean these guys
oh man these guys I know I know you
don't like cover bands it's and like I
do like a nice cover band with this was
just if they can get if they're killing
it this was depressing dude it was they
were [ __ ] I mean they had the pedal
set up the guy had like the one for the
Bon Jovi
wow out the voice box the talk box or
whatever Living on a Prayer get back to
work will you no your break end in an
hour ago Steve it was it was tough man
and then there was two guys I don't know
if there were Roadies or whatever but
they're the only ones in the audience
rock on yeah a couple of air guitars it
was a sad sad yeah it's for the kids
that's what I that's what I was these
guys were treated like it was [ __ ]
Woodstock these kids don't want to see
sticks what are we doing here it was bad
dude get somebody up there playing like
uh it was trashy trashy for sure spooky
songs they're all in cargo Shore it's
like real
real dad
Monster Mash that's what they should be
up there playing play play Monster
Mashers get a DJ get a DJ PAW Patrol
song the whole night out for the kids
these guys are over there [ __ ]
smoking Chiba before they go on it was
it was I was so embarrassed dude yeah it
was a tough one that's a tough look
that's a nice time though in the fall
there it's nice yeah sure go up there I
like it up there yeah too bad I was
thinking about this there's somebody
looking about moving up there I was no I
was you were talking about it yeah that
day or just in general just in general
really you need about a cool three mil
to get anything dude that is a price
you forget that
I mean like you know we grew up in the
suburbs of of Philly so it's like that
those are this you know these are the
richest people in the you know some of
the richest people in the world live
there sure you know what I mean because
you have like all these investment
bankers and [ __ ] and it's like
we're like I grew up with like
construction worker like people who are
the roofing companies and stuff like
that that was like the land was cheap
back then it was getting developed and
stuff like that it was starting to push
out from the city a little bit get a
decent mortgage you know you put 20 30
down whatever make some payments each
month people have that mind whatever I
don't know we go over this a lot I don't
understand how people say I know how my
mom and dad did it smoke and mirrors I
can refinance or refinance a couple of
forged pay stubs you don't know what was
going on working for ABC Contracting and
stuff like that shout out always
refinancing a little bit of this a
little bit of that little credit card
here a little bit she really made they
really made it work they know what
they're doing yeah yeah
um but all right let's get into it this
is a goddamn Family episode gang yes it
is Gang as you know when you sign up for
the old patreon there you get a question
read on the air on here you could choose
you choose bit of a backlog shout out to
Paul Versi a bit of a backlog but it's
the best way to do it and Kevin will do
that for you
right now I don't like when you do it
that way
all right let's go this one's from
backstage Jimmy what up James are you
garbage if your family rents a limo to
ride to your grandpa's funeral bonus
points it's of a Hummer limo because
that's all they have
that's a tough look do you showing up in
a yellow Hummer with spinners to bury
pop pop hot tub in the back we
accidentally we we we ignate that for my
dad's funeral what we don't want to do
the limo what'd you guys do you
typically get the nice limo not the I
mean that's wild yeah no use but they
have a diff there's a there's I assume
they were there's a few settlement
there's a funeral limpo
right it's a little bit closer it's a
little bit classier it's not like prom
hookers and Coke yeah I just didn't I
mean that would have been cool but uh I
just didn't I don't know I didn't feel
right about it plus coincidentally me
and my brother reach have black cars
it's a Jeep but I mean yeah well you
know what I mean it's still black so it
all it all kind of meshed in matched in
I don't know I saved a couple of bucks
though right you want what I got a car
is that for the driver I'll drive it
would have been pissed if it wasn't a
Hummer yeah plus I thought about my fat
ass getting in and out of that one
that's why you X they suck yeah yeah
yeah climbing that adapting I feel like
Farley you're digging my way out of the
window
um yeah that's a tough look that's tough
um this one's from Anthony Monaco ten
dollar homie shout out haven't had one
red is it garbage if you consider your
security deposit part of your net worth
yes and you should you should and your
savings account essentially I consider
that the last month's rent as well
that's that's trash that's on that's
that's place to place really
and now it shouldn't be that sure it
should I'm not waiting six weeks after I
get my new tickets 30 days isn't it get
out of here 30 day schmerty days listen
that's the rent I'll see you later I'll
drop the keys off in 29 days and I'll be
out of your hair
I've always done that
to the to the unhappiness of my landlord
sure yeah no one's thrilled about that
but the place is fine come in come in
and look at the plates but there's got
to be some sort of thing because I think
a lot of times I don't know if you I
don't think New York does but I think
that money's got to go in escrow
and something I don't know what that
means uh makes me hungry every time
somebody says it to them escrow go
um I I don't know I'm sure there's it
creates a little bit of a headache and
paperwork for them of
they can't just take that money on the
first of the last month
right they own the building they got it
whatever they get no they got to make
[ __ ] mortgage pay you don't know
whenever they'd pull it out then then
they have it that's not my listen their
banking isn't my business I'm out of the
contract no you're not sure I am no you
stiffed them on a month's rent no I
didn't yeah you did I'm not getting the
deposit back it all evens out that's not
what the security deposit is for you can
you come in and take a look at the place
and make sure it's okay but the rent's
due on the first of the month sure so
you're living there without paying rent
for 31 days and then you move out so
come and go hey you can take the money I
owed you 30 days ago in another 30 days
[Laughter]
you got to spend money to make money you
know what I'm talking about T-Bone um I
heard that yeah come in and take a look
at the place that's if I know I didn't
do anything to it I uh
otherwise slip the check out of the door
and we I I'd have some spackling to do
I'll tell you that my uh I've said
before Mike but they redo the place
anyway it doesn't matter most of the
time when you go out they come in and
they spackle and they paint and they
clean yeah they have to yeah so
you're going a real long way just to say
you're a dirtbag you're stiff in the
landlord in the last month which I hey
you know it is what it is I'm not
judging you for sure but don't try to
[ __ ] don't try to church it up you're
stiffing them burn the bridging way out
the door what are you doing I did that
by uh I I used to rent I rented to me my
friend rented a condo off my stepdad had
a rental property and against his better
judgment he rented it to us
and uh for rightfully so we
[ __ ] it up pretty bad really you're 22
24 Loco had just hit
shout out to Pat it's a glorious time
man a red Four Loco FDF it was like it's
if it was like somebody shot it with a
50 cal bullet dude this thing exploded
all over the walls whatever so I'm
trying to drinking so he kept my
security deposit my stepdad did let's
talk about playing Hardball but never
issued anything of like hey like and I
thought I think the security deposit was
1200 bucks or whatever the rent was a
thousand bucks
and I thought I was like hey it's gonna
be 500 to fix the carpets but like you
still owe me 500. so he was just like he
was like dude [ __ ] you I'm just keeping
the whole thing and I remember yelling
I'm like you owe me with this guy like I
like Googled the law or whatever and
like I quoted like you know section
three of the of the penal code Duncan
versus Robin
1893.
I'm like you had 30 days to to provide
me a written detailed docket of all
things and the horses are not to be tied
up on Main Street exactly [ __ ] couple
of horses Goodwill Baldi over here sent
me to my room
Kim how about that movement love that
movement baby talk about starting a
movement movement is starting to move it
gang since day one moving there's always
shaking things up if you want to get a
top quality watch at a [ __ ] discount
price do yourself a favor get over the
movement from day one they've been
shaking up the industry yeah guys uh you
can stand out with movement watches
eyewear and more during their Black
Friday seasonal sale baby with a
discount you can't mess you don't want
to miss this and you don't have to wait
in line like a bozo they were nice
enough they sent us the the blue the the
the blue blocking lens glasses they sent
me a watch and now I've got my got me
into the watch game I love it I got a
tight watch Flex on people I went out
and bought an expensive watch my wife
don't even like that one she likes the
movement it looks good it's good quality
there you go gotta love that baby
um Timeless time keeping within with a
fresh look movements designs come in
countless styles for every occasion shop
with confidence and joy 24 month
warranty free shipping and free returns
on orders over fifty dollars uh here we
go baby here's the turkey be a good
gifter with movement during Black Friday
sale get a special 25
off-site wide with code bf25 just in
time for the holidays join the movement
today at mvmt.com that's mvmt.com do it
okay let's talk about Helix mattress
baby you mean Helix mattress the best
than a goddamn business talk about Helix
you don't gotta wait in line over there
at The Mattress Store you take the quiz
on a website there they let you know how
you like to sleep sure then they give
you a mattress perfectly designed for
you yeah take two minutes leave quiz I
took it me and the bird got teamed up
with the Twilight
model Edition and baby let me tell you
did I jerk off in it today as I did with
the dog in there too oh my God
hachimachi uh you'll love uh you'll love
Helix mattress but don't take our word
for it they offer a hundred night
risk-free trial try out your new Helix
mattress see how your body adjusts and
if you decide it's not the best fit uh
you will ship it back full refund baby
everybody's unique everybody's sleeping
is different why would you sleep on
something why would you sleep on a
cookie cutter mattress you don't want to
do it take something that's good for you
uh plus Helix matches are American made
and come with a 10 or 15 year warranty
depending on the model don't want to
take my word for it Helix has been
awarded the number one mattress picked
by GQ and Wired Magazine baby now here
is the turkey Helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com garbage with Helix better
sleep starts and they'll do it took my
Four Loco oh man who the Cherry ones
they can get you those things came in
that was worse than the [ __ ] the
pillow it kind of went hand in hand they
did it yeah yeah they did I like a Red
Bull and vodka and a perkanoon
get your hands see your eyes roll back
in your head look like a Vegas slot
machine a couple of those it was always
Christmas
all these eyes are spinning pinpoint
pimply pinpoint
um all right this one's from Bozo Bowser
Bozer Bozo bozaferson
um I like that have you ever played air
guitar in a pool stick yeah some of my
best work
I love the pool stick we used to love
playing with the pool stick take it
apart I was terrible those were big take
it apart not everybody had to take a
porter The Rake too playing with the
rake too I had no idea not a rake it's a
bridge I believe is the name of it
whatever the rake it's not a crap table
you idiot
[Music]
oh steak that in the chalk chop your
finger in there man it makes my blood
run cold the chalk was a good time yeah
um
yeah we never had a pool table a couple
of buddies did yeah neither did we was
always at a friend's house yeah a couple
of buddies something was always missing
too you were either missing a ball the
[ __ ] triangle was broke yeah all you
had was a little stick it was always a
little stick yeah there's a little they
the little stick comes with the set for
when you're in a corner that's what you
use the bridge with
no the bridge you use with a regular I
think Toby give that a Google I think I
think a full the bridge is also known as
the lady stick or something no yeah
you're like a real a true true player is
not supposed to use it unless you're you
know a bit of a pansy I think the word
is I think I I thought a full uh cue
stick set came with a little that's what
that's from Seinfeld you idiot the
maestros [ __ ] up that was the thing but
there is an actual small cue a small
stick to eu's when you're in a tight
corner now when you're in a tight corner
you go up with it pop them down anything
I'm not exactly sure what I'm supposed
to do
it's your small pool stick okay
pull stick set okay okay not pool
noodles I was like is this about the
bridge or the little stick I missed the
whole pool noodles thing that was that
was after my time yeah you just get
regular ones you'd have to like special
order a little guy oh really yeah you're
for sure thinking of that scene in
Seinfeld no no I remember my friend had
one I've seen them at bars where there's
little ones yeah it's generally for a
poorly placed table Yeah but they do
make them well why can't he find them I
don't know this whole thing's fishy no
maybe maybe you think you know better
than Google
possibly
okay but I do like a little air guitar
on one of those things they were a broom
was the best a boy had a good base a
broom you were stopping the show
finger exercises yeah short cues for
every room size see there you go thank
you whack thank you that's [ __ ] get out
of here you owe me an apology never at
300
um Foley versus Ryan
all right this one's from Thomas uh 50
homie here is a garbage to lie about the
tier of your patreon
that's just a good time right there 800
homie here that is that's what I laughed
at earlier I was like I was like oh
that's a fun one because I had the same
I'm like 50 all right you got me that's
a good time shout out to it
um I just from Wizard is it garbage to
bring a first date to a gun range
it depends where you live I mean that
kind of could be like a thing
I guess yeah if you're like right More
Country folk you know yeah your shooters
a lot of camo involved in that
relationship I presume let's certainly
let you know you're a man if you got
your own piece a hunting rifle or
whatever it is that's got to be tough if
she takes you and you are not uh you're
not a you're not a marksman and you're
like yeah I gotta you got the rental gun
or whatever that's you're in the rental
skates
that's a tall floor it was a terrible
shot yeah uncle Hank you're bad oh man
we never give me the uzi
you're every bad guy in the 80s oh man
give me the who's here the shotgun I'm a
shotgun man uh terrible
I don't know if I've ever really shot at
anything
you know we were just like shooting into
like the wall the woods and shoot at
canes or anything like that
wasn't the [ __ ] Wild Wild West no BB
gun I'm okay we used to yeah you can't
really gauge that though we used to hang
out on my boy Mike DelVecchio's in
college over to his place he was he was
boys that my my one boy to go over and
we'd spend hours over there just boozing
smoking doobies and just shooting the
cans in his backyard but just taking
turns it was awesome my boy uh all my my
boys I went to Drexel uh they had like a
mouse or rat there's a there's a lot of
a lot of live creatures like squirrels
and stuff
in their house
squirrels in their house if it was a bad
property
keep that security deposit oh man you
should do that basement was like they
they shut it one time I was like all
right just locked away really whatever
was going on there's all ecosystem down
there it was bad yeah I thought they
would shoot they had BB guns and they
would shoot the mice the mice now mice
no mice
they started the [ __ ] bubonic plane
no they proved that wasn't them
it was guinea pigs he has guinea pigs
yeah
my blood wasn't off the mice
it wasn't dogs all right
I couldn't hurt a guinea pig I only have
one body on me you say that like I have
been hurting guinea pigs uh I only have
one body on me I just [ __ ] Wing one a
bunny we shot a bunny
in the backyard
with a with a BB gun
we say this like as a family you did
this that was me my brother we shot him
we went outside they showed up with dark
chocolate it was in the cage but you
know wait the Easter Bunny healthy
snacks that's pretty good uh no it was
me 90 cacao
yeah you remember those remember
remember those hollow bunnies at Easter
back in the day those things saw oh I
like those lighting an ear on that
solid or nothing no but they were big
that was the thing yeah they were real
shitty chocolate that was like eating
wax who cares I ate that right after I
ate the peeps and if I was eating Peeps
and I was in a bad way it might as well
been vegetables
I had one once and I looked I remember
looking at my mom and go these never end
up in a basket ever again don't even
bring them in the house I don't care
where you got them take them away get
them out of here give her a slap cheers
[ __ ] bringing peeps around now my
cousin had gotten a BB gun and we
thought we were tough guys and we went
out and we were like you know just
shooting at whatever and then there's a
rabbit and we shot it and we kept
missing and I hit it but didn't didn't
kill it and then we had to go up and
[ __ ] put her out of its misery we
were such a little little girls about it
yeah we ended up bearing it we stood
around we said a prayer and stuff like
that never touched a rifle again that
was it but I was done killing file up
the serial numbers throw it in the water
It's haunting me ever since Toby we hit
up we lit up a snake one time
we got a semi-automatic handgun where
you just had to like a real one no no no
BB gun
um
and you just had to like it had a
trigger on the back handle like a button
where like yeah like squeeze hard enough
and then you could just and it had like
a clip you would put like 16 or whatever
you know 20 PBS in pellets are BBS
babies Pelicans were like trikes they
they were like Allure of the 80s you
couldn't get your hands on pellet guns
or trikes I knew a kid that had one I
remember I remember him it was my
brother's friends and he got underneath
the car and there was a kid riding a 10
speed down our street and he lit him up
while he was driving they would get like
in your skin dude [ __ ] up pellets were
bad [ __ ] this kid up right in the ankle
It's gotta still be in them yeah that
was the big thing everybody knew
somebody with a BB and I'm like do you
feel that Yani still has a bullet in him
Jesus yeah Johnny P got lit up God
was back when he was banging in the
clubs shout out to Johnny P I think he
grew out
actually and he had to go in and get it
comes out yeah like your body will
ultimately reject I have a piece of
pencil on my pinky
so I'm all scarred up too I know how it
is
uh but [ __ ] what was I gonna say
oh it's a murder in an innocent snake
first of all there's no such thing as an
innocent snake they're Devil's creatures
I thought I'll give you
get out of here baby no way you read the
Bible what are we doing the New
Testament does not look at them
favorably no
um
and we were walking by and uh I don't
know it was my brother I forget I just
remember [ __ ] this snake we were
walking by we had this Pond by my dad's
house and uh
and like right that's all it took yeah
and I think it's my brother maybe just
like and just hit him and like lace this
thing with like six BBS yeah buried it
at a funeral did you really no we gotta
run at a Hummer limo too
now we buried the rabbit every time I
walked by it I'd look at it and think
about that poor Raven yeah it sucks but
you know we're gonna do what are you
gonna do your kids made some mistakes
but then we went to an actual shooting
range when I was I don't know probably
with your family and her friends I don't
know they keep saying we I don't know I
wasn't I don't know how many friends you
had growing up so I just assume it's
your family
me and my aunt now my buddy who was in
the Army took us to an outdoor shooting
range he had the AR-15 and a handgun I
was terrible shooting that little that
little um
one of the little red the little red
things little Clay Jones whatever
they're called oh like skeet shooting he
didn't throw them up we just set them up
against the hill
yeah we should go skeet shooting that
should be uh what a shotgun yeah kind of
cash to do that don't you I think we're
doing all right yeah
pretty cool I feel like it's easy though
everybody I know goes like I shot nine
out of ten it's like It's gotta be not
that hard you're spraying with you're
shooting a buck shot you're not shooting
22s no right that spreads out yeah
spread on it's like [ __ ] 10 feet or
they could be lying I don't know so I'll
be I know a couple of people are like
yeah I [ __ ] killed I'm like
this seems like it would be the hardest
thing in the world and you're just
walking in 100 lighting it up that
doesn't make sense yeah it's like
frisbee golf
um shout out to Burke Chrysler big
Frisbee golf guy is he yeah I didn't
know that then we had him on the tour
bus oh we did yeah they were like
sitting on the I didn't see him yeah
um uh all right here let's see here this
one's from Seth uh have you or anyone in
your family ever ran yourself over with
a four-wheeler
foreign
like going over the handlebars and had
it run over you
that was one of the original questions
that did you know anybody that was
injured in an ATV oh really yeah yeah
man I was I I I uh I fell off one pretty
bad scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me my
boys had these 125 cc quad Runners they
were called they were like Hondas and we
rode a lot like as kids
um where
in your mom's neighborhood oh no oh no
he lived he lived on like one of those
like Toll Brother developments yeah when
it backed up to like the woods right
like yeah like you know railroad or
whatever that was like small it was like
you would just take him right out in the
backyard yeah Jesus cops call me [ __ ]
gotta hide out somewhere your fat ass
I'm gunning it
get off of me man
I flipped my cousin my dad's a lawyer I
flip my cousin's ATV a sideways or
backwards sideways I went backwards
learned a harsh lesson about leaning oh
yeah you gotta lean into it even when
you feel like you shouldn't uh we were
doing these things they call like I
guess they're called hill climbs we're
like you
it's like a steep hill and you like
[ __ ] gun it and go up yeah yeah I've
seen the videos so they all did it and
like they it was him and his brother and
they had their quads like that they were
their quads and I was just on like their
their other one I assume they weren't
little pieces of [ __ ] nah not really uh
but they knew what they were doing and
they're like yeah just [ __ ] you know
when you get it there's like a system
because it was like a quick like scooper
like right up
um oh I never would have done that it
was like a spine you know what I mean
like a spine ramp and he was like you
gotta punch it if you punch it in the
wrong spot you're gonna [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's one of those things where like
everything got quiet and I'm in the air
like I [ __ ] I punched at the wrong
time and I killed yourself oh dude I am
for sure I am full blown in the air just
like oh
I can see a little bowl cut oh dude you
probably have like a milk mustache
fruit punch
e
dude and I start slowly get out I can do
and it hit me like this [ __ ] dude like
this sucks man and I [ __ ] dude and it
fell I because you can't you don't have
like momentum to get away from it you
know what I mean so I'm on it and
they're like let go so I let go and I
land and it lands and thank God it
landed on it they had the what are they
called like uh
Fender rat like it had a rack on it
which kind of prevented it from like it
felt like the quad fell upwards you know
crushing your large best and skull
especially my little wee-wee
yeah actually and I remember I was like
one of those things where you like
immediately want to call your mom
I think I'm so sorry for everything
[Music]
I promise I won't eat in bed anymore
oh man now I got the it was the perfect
timing
for the fear of those things to be put
into us where we wouldn't even go near
them because it was in the 80s
like one in two kids were getting killed
on those things yeah because they had
just kind of come out and they were
dangerous as [ __ ] they hadn't worked out
the balance of them and this and that
and they they still still haven't worked
out the ganks and some poor kid got
really really hurt in our neighborhood
on one nope never went near them I was
always uh
afraid of like [ __ ] like I was never
like the crazy one of like let's [ __ ]
you know try to do wheelies or whatever
I was just like
good at cruising like it would snow we'd
be like all right let's [ __ ] take the
quads and we'll go like build a
snowboard ramp on the hill low and slow
baby yeah crew
Cruz you know what I mean take a look no
thanks that was the best part of it
um home run of a [ __ ] question yeah
okay but you know about men mobile love
mint mobile baby I'm a client that's
right mint mobile shout out to him gang
what are you doing paying high prices
for phone service 15 bucks a month to
admit mobile no contracts no fees no
hiddenness no hidden that a lot of
people say to me they come up to
Ministry to say Hey fatty but what's the
catch I say there is no catch they pass
the savings run on you because it's all
done online over there at mint mobile
yeah guys uh like like I've said a
million times at this point man it's
been a long time supporter of us and my
wife has been using mint mobile since
before this podcast even started that's
how my that's how big of a fan we are
over there at the Ryan residence there
you go for anyone who hates their phone
bill mint mobile offers premium Wireless
for just 15 bucks a month mint mobile
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying one one or a family and Men the
family started two lines they know what
they're doing all plans come with
unlimited talking text high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network
use your own phone with any mint Mobile
plan and keep the same number along with
your existing contacts switch submit
mobile to get premium wireless service
start at just 15 a month here's the
turkey get premium Wireless 15 bucks a
month with no unexpected plot twist at
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage seriously you'll
make your wallet very happy
mintmobile.com garbage do it okay let's
talk about that established titles one
more time baby you mean the best in the
biz yeah talking to a couple Lords of
garbage right here gang when you buy
just as little as one square foot of
Scottish Woodlands over there everyone's
got to call you a lawyer a lady they
send you a certificate it's a good time
you can tell your boss to go [ __ ]
himself call me the Lord what are we
doing here yeah it don't matter if you
work at Target Burger King anywhere you
are a MF and Lord Daddio how great would
it be the next time you get pulled over
by the cheese on the highway yeah hey do
you know how fast I was going I don't
know talk to my lady that's what I would
say guys the first 200 people purchase a
title pack using our link will
effectively be next to our place but in
a few walking even within a few minutes
of walking let's be names yeah create a
landed trash well you borrow my Cannon
sometimes our own little kingdom out
there baby uh here's the cheese
established titles running a Black
Friday sale plus if you use the code
garbage you'll get an additional 10 go
to establishtitles.com garbage get your
gifts now and help support the channel
Baby One More Time establish titles.com
now back to the show I have a quick one
for you fellas I'm listening when you
put your deodorant on after getting out
of the shower okay do you put your shirt
on first or after
that's weird what do you do I've put my
deodorant on first never you put your
shirt on first yeah because it gets on
your shirt
why do you want it on your shirt I don't
want it on my shirt what are you talking
about if you put it on first and then
you put it gets on it can get on the
sides of on the exterior of your shirt
oh I use Clear deodorant yeah sometimes
it still shows I just don't want to do
it no never I also use white deodorant
that's crazy that's crazy too well I
also use a
alarming amount of really yeah to the
point where I did it one time the fact
they use antiperspirants crazy that's
what you use you you use deodorant
antiperspirant what's that
antiperspirant is different you don't
know this I do anti-personal I just use
it from sweating yeah I use Dove I don't
think it's antiperspirant it wouldn't be
white it wouldn't just be it wouldn't be
white if it was if it was just deodorant
I'm pretty sure no because it's the
girls deodorant I don't think it's any I
don't think it's any person most girls
deodorant is antiperspirant
antipersman deodorant that's what we're
it's a combo it has them both in there
I think I'm not supposed to use that
[ __ ] either
it's no good for you yeah deodorant Mass
odor while an antiperspirant reduces how
much sweat the antiperspirant contains
the aluminum the aluminum yeah oh I'm
cool with it then I don't care
well that's why I smoke cigs for [ __ ]
20 years that's why you're putting uh
the shirts I no out of the shower get
towed off dry use the blow dryer and we
know and every crevice every Valley
than deodorant so so nothing starts up I
don't want nothing cooking do my spray
my Gold Bond spray then start getting
dressed now I go shirt and then what do
you do I just switched what were you I
was I was in a shirt on guy and then
you'd reach under and yeah yeah yeah
yeah but then I but then I kept catching
the sides of the shirt you get the weird
I was like where where's all this chalk
coming from or whatever sure yeah
because I had I had got jammed up bought
some white deodorant never do it never
always it was all over the shirt so now
I'm like what brand what brand are you
using I use Old Spice I also use Old
Spice yeah but sometimes you catch a bad
batch of that I used it for a long time
too where it's like super alcoholy it's
because it's that's alcohol based or
something yeah no wonder I like it
two more Old Spice please Old Spice and
soda I'll catch a bad [ __ ] it feels like
someone hit me with a blow torch under
there I had like I react poorly oh you
have sensitive skin a little burn
oh body it's Mary Jesus Christ
flipping ATVs can't handle things I was
man enough to get on the horse all right
hey I'll give you that oh I was smart
you ever use the gel remember when the
gel was popular that stuff's Speed Stick
might as well been using [ __ ] glue
yeah
dude that was nasty but I remember
putting on deodorant my boy Pat goes
what are you doing
and
I think how much how and I was thinking
he goes That's he goes That's crazy like
I go
what do you think about 79 I think yeah
to eight one two three four five six
seven eight no it's okay maybe at that
seem too short
I go a little bit longer it's a lot I go
a little bit I ruined shirts I go longer
too because I have more surface area to
cover sure I got to make sure I get out
here I can't oh you gotta get down here
if there was a bigger guy yeah I know
I'm aware I'm a fat piece of [ __ ] you
don't want to be stinking nah so I used
to have dude I used to have a stick in
my car so like if I never get jammed up
you know what I mean
I never got that Bo smell okay now it
takes now it takes a long time like I'll
get like a I'll get like a funky smell
before I get like the hoagie smell yeah
yeah never I've never really gotten that
all right new kids in high school man
Now High School your body's changing
your figuring stuff out smelling like a
Greek salad brutal never got it
never got it
not much of a man though uh uh did I I
think I think I told the story where I
wore the the hoodie that had been in the
wash too long and it took me to like
third period you know how so it smells
like mold or whatever
you know what I mean yeah
kick it like a fish tank so I'm like
it's I'm like I smelled it on the boss
or the call like you know what I mean
but like I was like oh it's clearly not
me whatever it is I was sitting in
[ __ ] social studies or something and
I was like hike the kid behind the kid
in front of me AJ's like what the [ __ ]
and I'm like oh this is big
and you're doing the thing and then
you're like nah oh it's not bad you're
like oh this is I'm J and it's a whole
thing it's not like you even spilled
something or it's in the pits the whole
thing's [ __ ] ingratiated who's been
eating turtle
hahaha
needless to say I ran down to the gym
and got somebody's [ __ ] ex body spray
out of the locker
talking about a lifesaver I was walking
back man static that stuff had its place
in time didn't it yeah
shout out to it man that stuff would be
cold on your underarms too
much that was mostly Freon
Annie purse burning [ __ ] Freon spray
glycerol putting that down on your nuts
that'll [ __ ] sting we used to do a
thing in high school where you take the
bottle of ax body spray put like a bead
or some type of ball on top and then
tape it so it was like spraying like a
solid grenade and then out of your room
and hold it close damn that's [ __ ]
awesome [ __ ] I wish I would have done
that I don't ruin a day
we did that with stink bombs back in the
day the little glass stink bombs they
were a good time throw those in the
hallway you know the hallways and in
schools that like you know they were
like column hallways
stairs stairs yeah yeah not a hallway
but oh yeah stairs sorry you know the
things that aren't always
stairs yeah man
I don't know what they're called guys in
quicksand tonight
throw one of those down there
look at everybody be halfway on the bus
smoke bombs were a good time too as a
kid when were you doing not in school
lots of Columbine Jesus Christ
because back in the day they did do
those they do cherry bombs and all that
stuff cherry bombs cherry bombs are like
uh give a cherry bomb a [ __ ] I'm not
it's a kind of like an M80 they would
blow up the toilets in the 50s and [ __ ]
with them yeah I mean I don't know they
flush cherry bombs down the toilet yeah
I mean
you're getting proper trouble if you
blow up a toilet I think that would be a
felony at this point yeah yeah right
T-Bone yeah they're illegal now
but what's the water oh Cherry Bomb
it's like a firecracker yeah like an M80
I know they are it's the wattage every
m80s are heavy we used to go down and my
dad would go down to South Carolina
every year and come back with I mean we
went we would just [ __ ] then the one
year he came back with ones that had
waterproof Wicks damn it was a good time
pretty a frogman oh man we were just
throwing them in the water that's back
in the harbor oh it was great dude dude
m80s I saw a time I know exactly which
everybody I've lit about 10 000 of them
in my life yeah we had our college dorms
were quads and there was uh there was
three floors and there was trouble and
one of the things it's troubled Noel and
they sent uh the security guards were
walking through the quad and somebody
threw a couple m80s like out there third
floor window at the security guys too
like right next to this dude's head just
boom boom boom it's like everybody hit
the ground especially in a quad too like
that Echo yeah
no bueno dicey but those smoke bombs
were a good time they're different
colors a little
looking for an extraction playing war in
the woods I knew I was going to be
smoking Bernies for a long time I was
gonna have a love affair with heaters uh
because we used to fake those smoke
those fake cigs not even the candy
cigarettes they used to sell actual fake
cigarettes with like a red tin foil on
the end they use them in high school
plays and [ __ ] you blow out looks like
smoke yeah
some sort of chemical for sure it wasn't
organic and you would get them at Party
City
and just we would take our bikes we ride
up to Party City get like they were like
two packs or three packs and just
[ __ ] cruise around smoking fake
heaters I got my hands on the real thing
a couple guys on the pegs a side cart
couldn't tell me nothing
I could Stingers that's great candy
cigarettes is one thing with the bubble
gum it was the 90s dude my dad was a
heater man my stepdad was his dad before
him was a heater man I [ __ ] earned my
keep out there
man not smoking one of those hanging in
your mouth as you flip the ATV
all right this one's from uh
uh champi uh 38 homie here there you go
don't understand that it's got to be a
withdrawal yeah 30 these are probably a
five dollar homie with the 35 overdraft
fee that's all right there's 33 over
Jeffy
um you don't get that at Navy Federal
what I don't think there's overdraft
fees there's God I would assume that's
that's how Banks live and die by the
over that's where they make like
a large chunk of their money in retail
banking yeah
I ever get your rocks off as a kid and
tug your route to National Geographic
sure yeah I don't know I don't know we
would only ever see those at school or
the doctors we had a we had a collection
of them I don't know where my parents
got them but that was hot are you an
encyclopedia family sure really
encyclopedia yep whoa yeah we had them
we had them the britannica's or whatever
we didn't have Britannica it was some
off-brand
yeah it was something it was like Earls
babies
but yeah we had we had a whole set of
those maybe missing a couple yeah you
guys are a b and c yeah had to rest on
layaway I remember I remember
plagiarizing those things down to the
commas and the periods for uh uh what
are they called book reports yeah
um big time
yeah I don't think we ever uh catch a
boob or two in there too one of them an
encyclopedia yeah very clinical yeah
I found your k for knockers let's go
but no National Geographic hundred
percent yeah no we just that was
something that was like we never got our
[ __ ] hands on that I never saw that
[ __ ] yeah I mean like you would see like
you know
uh we also I also had a bunch of female
girl cousins who all they had all the
cosmos like I mean all of them I
remember reading on how to give a good
blow job at 11. let me tell you boys man
pulling your route to those whoosh I
mean some of those photo shoots were
pretty risque also at the time because
now you can see whatever went especially
in the 80s you'd have like a little silk
cover and a little nip something like
that it was there you know it was there
but you need it but that way you could
you could get charged up off way less
because you were there was no exposure
to anything else you know what I mean so
it was like a girl in a bathing suit
that's why like maximum that was all
pre-internet yeah like maximum magazine
you're like whoa
yeah now I gotta hit this thing with a
hammer
come on it's got to be a real nerd I
need the neighbor everybody put a candle
open something yeah the party don't
start until the butthole starts opening
up
I need to see a prolapse you know what
I'm talking about
this one's in the same world it's from
Jack Van delay have you ever used Cliff
Notes as an adult I could never I was
always fascinated by Cliff Notes my
sister had a one set you would hear it
it would be like jokes on like Saved by
the Bell or Steph I never understood
what it was I go I why is anybody then
reading anything if you got that my
sister had I remember seeing it it was
black and yellow yeah I always saw the
Cliffhanger every time I heard a Cliff's
Notes yeah I didn't get it I still don't
fully get it it just gives you a
synopsis of the book that and Mad Libs I
never really quite understood oh man I
remember laughing at Mad Libs my buddy
Matt had a book and I was like this is
the I am the funny like because it goes
give me a noun and you're like Doritos
give me your thoughts give me a verb die
you know whatever and then you read that
thing man as an eight-year-old with no
phone no Internet no TV that's a good
time I didn't know where you got Cliff
Notes either I think I asked my mom a
couple of times to get him but no you're
not cheating Terry again get out of here
she just ended up doing a book report at
nine o'clock that night anyway while I
was watching Airwolf yeah so you should
have just got me to Cliff Notes lady the
dump run is for you
hey save yourself six hours today junior
I got Nightcore coming on in 20 minutes
honey what are we doing here let's go
what are you gonna not let me know it
get out of here yeah I was uh no never
happened my mom would not let my mom
would be like go face your consequences
like I guess you knew like they the
grades didn't necessarily
you know fifth grade
it did though it didn't matter
where you get placed your fourth grade
if you're
you lose what 10 points they're not
gonna give you a [ __ ] zero for it
sure you know yeah I always kind of do
that yeah so my mom's like go face the
consequences and tell him you don't have
it like that's more of a life lesson of
like
being accountable you could still use uh
we swept on a rug yeah we're like the
Kennedy's bag
um this one's from Jordan uh
uh are you garbage you ever fist fought
a clown because he scared your little
brother I like that that's real dirt bag
[ __ ] and I respect it yeah why don't you
pick on someone your own size [ __ ] yeah
really go after enough with the pranks
and the clowns and this and that I do
like a haunted house though like what
you know where the actors are oh I love
that it's a good time love Halloween and
it's the best
we went to one it's called Uh it was
like a civil war
uh uh old civil war base in like Dover
Delaware or something we drove down to
and like sixth or seventh grade
and I had you know it was scare there
was like it was like you know theater
school kids or you know college kids you
didn't know that though man this guy was
painted white and he had dreadlocks and
he was walking around and he's he was
scaring me in the line before he even
got into the [ __ ] event he lit up one
of your fig cigarettes that's what is he
here buddy
I need a stick to calm my nerves to get
my head on straight before I go in here
but man that's the idea now that I'm a
big jumper I get I get jolted I don't
like it
I'm a jumpy man yeah that stuff's no
bueno yeah scare you I love being scared
though
I hate it I'll fall I'll get into like
an Instagram hole and like looking at
like what's scaring you on Instagram
they have like you know videos of like
UFOs and like you know Paranormal
Activity and haunted things
I don't know if I can trust anything on
Instagram you know what they get you is
the fake audio it's it's different audio
than what's in the thing you know enough
about audio to be like yeah yeah of
course yeah you're like this this is
this surveillance camera didn't have
Dolby Surround Sound or whatever you
know what I mean yeah yeah hey you can
tell it doesn't match up
uh although I do believe in that stuff
what
that those kind of like ghost videos the
one that Sal and Chris just posted
looked pretty scary it's a lady walking
by it's the biggest video they said
nobody was there that's what people
would say Hey listen if it was just
posted online that's one thing Sal said
that a friend of those two girls who's
he's friends with him said there was
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq
people want to get what they want Sal
didn't need nothing to do with that I
thought it could have been a big break
Sal and the boys are in uh Colin
Powell's here they'll tell them there's
weapons
hold up the little jar hold up the
little jar
foreign
the whole no-press network almost been
pumped into homeless pimp the other day
me too he's a good man he's a good man
he's a good man that pimpy all right
um let's see here this is from David
Smith
do you say else instead of else
anyone else I think I might throw a t in
there anyone else
anyone else else it's not else I don't
say that else and maybe I dropped the E
anyone else what's else yeah that's
pretty good that's pretty trash what
else is pretty trash else is trash or do
you say alls in place of all that as in
alls I'm trying to say all I'm trying to
say yeah all I'm trying to say yeah I
think what are you supposed to say all
that I'm trying to say
all that I'm trying to say is all I'm
trying to say is yeah
I felt like a glove that did all
sometimes all I'm saying is all I'm
saying yeah I I've said it before but my
buddy his family used to say every wears
anywheres I
I can't find my glove anywheres I assume
this is the family that have the ATVs no
no different family different family I
had more than one friend unlike you
um
yeah I just remember that was like I was
like what in the f I remember going home
I would go home and like dish to my mom
will you see what these like you get a
load of these this I thought we were
[ __ ] up these people are nuts cause
I'm gonna give her a big hug
to my book report
I think I told you that on the beach my
cousins it was like the first time I
stayed at the I was with my cousins what
cousins cousins is bad cousins cousins
you [ __ ] walked right into that my
cousin's a real trash
my cousins can't find my cousins
anywheres
have you seen my presents cousin yeah
because
I say cousin my cousin two of my cousins
two of my cousins I throw a z in there
too I think
guzance
what are we I don't know but you talk
like alphabet soup
my cousins [ __ ] mush mouths over here
going on my cousins for Christmas
more
man
he can't find his perks anywheres
gotta go help my cousins look for his
Percocets
he don't know he stole them two weeks
ago
plot twist I'm never gonna find him hey
buddy yeah you believe that
oh I've done that
I've joined a search party for drugs
that I had taken oh really
stole
he got the lantern out
hey wherever whatever you do don't check
my bloodstream huh boys
oh man you dirt bag
that's [ __ ] up that somebody would
take that man I don't think I've ever
done that but I definitely
uh
uh I definitely will take I'm looking
I'm taking a peek at your medicine
cabinet
even now I probably will if I'm using
your bathroom I'm taking a peek
I don't uh Pharmaceuticals never really
did it for me sure so it's like I don't
even I don't even have that uh impulse
but I would take a peek just to see
what's allergic to the painkillers
yikes kids at home it's never in the
medicine cabinet you want to check under
the sink of course maybe a broken ankle
18 months ago sure but then again kids
don't do
drug seeking Behavior it's bad look at
the you know you want to be like these
two idiots
has anyone had a root canal recently
no of course of course stay away clear
my dentist at huh but yeah then you
can't you can't you start looking under
the sink and in the closet I mean you're
one step away from going through the
drawers sure you take a gentleman takes
a peek in the medicine no he doesn't if
something comes up and see a guy who
doesn't pay the last month's rent
[Laughter]
if something comes up in your favor well
that's just the way the universe went
you can't start rooting around what do
you call going through the medicine God
Peak I'm looking for dental floss
I got chicken stuck in my tooth I don't
know I didn't have dinner yet I had a
sandwich before I came it was the car
I didn't want to eat too much be that as
it may I'll lock the door and run the
water like a gentleman a quick beat no
no don't do that
that's in poor taste of course of course
um all right I really want to check the
nightstand
I mean you want to yeah
okay that got a little too real and too
sad you want to you want to check the
nightstand but I remember it and I think
I remember
just yeah that was that was every that
we were like we were like we worked at
Scotland Yard that's all we did was root
through each of our friends houses yeah
over 13 or whatever you're looking for
porn every anything something something
to take back to the bosses I know
something kick up something to kick off
to kick up to the big man you know what
I mean it dude it didn't matter it was
it was just so interesting whatever
y'all she's got this your mom does this
and it didn't matter anything we went
through the whole entire house we found
I mean why one bodies have found
everything [ __ ] you don't want to see
everything
drugs mugs whips change handguns it's
crazy that's just my mom's bedroom
uh
um all right let's see this is from MV
why whatever bunch of letters uh first
time long time ever put dryer sheets in
your shoes while wearing them to prevent
the smell when going to someone's house
where you can't wear shoes
that's a great idea I wish I would have
thought of that I've done it a bunch it
doesn't work I've used cologne that's
the worst that creates a
must that you can't shake now as a
modern person as an adult I like wearing
I like no socks in a fresh pair of
sneakers I know I think that's it's bad
I think I think it's nice because you
know you're being naughty you shouldn't
be doing it no I do it and I'm like this
is bad but I don't care it feels so a
little naughty today my sophomore year
of Lacrosse in college I played every
year I played every game with no socks I
never wore socks that's different sports
a lot of athletes don't wear socks oh
really I didn't know that yeah it makes
you feel faster and I've Loved no socks
but
is absolutely no longer the same shoe I
don't care if it's the first thing the
you've before you even try them on it's
they're no longer the same shoe the
second you do that 100
um I did it it's not good
my boy flip used to we lived together
for like whatever eight years or
something like that he used to put them
in the freezer his sneakers yeah would
you wear them with no shoes with no
socks no but I also think back just
kicked and college socks were a problem
sure you know what I mean like they
weren't you couldn't just Amazon new
song like and then if you're living with
a room full of dudes or like a house
full of dudes stealing everybody's socks
I remember I [ __ ] shout out to my boy
Eddie who came to the Orlando show you
were like the really good looking kid
okay
um
shout out to Eddie spaghetti he [ __ ]
I was doing my laundry we were living at
Temple I did my laundry and it was on
the couch like because I guess the
laundry was down there wherever the [ __ ]
it was my stuff was on the couch like I
folded it on the couch it was sitting
there and I had one pair of socks that
I'm like all right I'm gonna put I'm
gonna go shower put these on then go to
class is all I had I watched my only
pair of socks and this [ __ ] Dirtbag
had come home or whatever saw my pair of
socks and took the like put them on and
then went to class I chased them down
the [ __ ] street I'm like you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] let me see your [ __ ]
are they Adidas let me see them I'm [ __ ]
dude he's like nah man I thought they
were mine oh man it was like that was a
part of my net worth [ __ ] security
deposit your socks were like currency
and in your 20s
ah it's a good time things weren't going
great that's a good time but
I've gotten into that habit of wearing
them with no especially I'm running out
of running out of the apartment to grab
something or take the trash out sure
walk the dog I do a lot dude slip them
in it's no good I just had to when we
left here on
uh Friday
uh we were doing something in the city
and my feet would I can't dude I just
went and bought a new pair of shoes and
gave them I was like just throw these
out they were like what and then the guy
was having the guy at the counter throw
the shoes out yeah I wore them out all
right but you take the old shoes out No
I gave him the Box
you go throw that out that's not their
job to throw out your dirty I said here
can you throw this out can you get rid
of this yeah no that's really that's
that's in poor taste how many people you
think did that that day
none you shouldn't be the only guy asked
him to throw dude to be at a point where
you gotta throw out your character
there's no trash can in there where in
the store yeah you take them out with
you and you that's your responsibility
so what happens if you wear the shoes
out I've done this what do you mean you
okay you're going to buy a pair of
sneakers you wear the shoes out yeah
what do you do with the other sneakers
you put them in the new box put them in
the news what if you're gonna throw them
out throw them out in the street that's
your responsibility you're giving
someone your shoes you don't even want
anymore because they smell so bad that's
just to me that's not oh really yeah
that's your responsibility I thought I
thought it was a nice tip yeah you can
smell them if you want all the whips you
need keep the laces if you'd like
I wouldn't get near anything else yeah
no really that's just how I feel how I
operate it as a person of like that's
your mess take huh take your mess with
you so I'm a dirt ball
I mean yeah I've been pretty vocal about
that over the past couple of years
uh yeah I would say next time you're
jammed up that's a youth that's your hmm
that's your mess okay all right I see
your point mm-hmm I see your point
um all right let's do one more then we
got a wrapper up here this is from trash
compactor ever use your pet as a napkin
mm-hmm I guess you got like Dorito dust
on it you give him a shimmy I get it I
get it I don't I just I mean I just got
a pup
but I don't think so I don't think I
have now
kind of like that dog that dog smell
yeah it's like whatever's on there is
food I don't want to trade then you have
food you have like Dorito dust and my
clothes of course my pants my shirt
yeah my shirt does everything people a
lot of people do jeans the inside like
the pockets of your jeans oh yeah to
your legs sure back on my knees I'll put
I'll put if if I sneeze and like uh you
know
you also 90 phlegm some egg white hits
the hits of my hand that'll go right
that'll go right back behind my hand and
I'll I'll squeeze my leg and then give
it
you also sneeze like an old man just
full open Palm right into your hands
yeah yeah you also sneeze like you
swallowed a Cherry Bomb by the way
those things are violent I know
they feel so good it's like you're doing
karate
you gotta wrap it up gang we love you to
death thank you for everything hey do
yourself a favor as we said make sure
you pick up your set of cards there
because they're going away they're going
bye-bye they might be going by the time
this comes out so don't get your hopes
up if there are some pick some up act
now gang jump on a patreon subscribe on
YouTube go over there to the iTunes
subscribe over there give us a review
The Whole Nine Yards you know what to do
you're the army of garbage we love you
and we'll see you next week peace